paul alliès maxime thiébaut bonjour à
tous les deux merci d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce matin sur rtl france
on lisait une abstention record dimanche
dernier emmanuel macron l'a reconnu il
va devoir tirer des conséquences en
matière institutionnelle à l'abstention
elle s'accentue un maintenant depuis
plusieurs années alors dans ce contexte
la france
est-ce qu'elle a besoin de se réinventer
avec une sixième république paul alliès
on commence avec vous le diagnostic
volet de fer parle de lui-même cette se
résume la vème république que repose sur
un énorme paradoxe puisque chez le
président de la république et lui seul
qui est totalement irresponsable devant
le parlement à dia qui décident ou ne
décide pas à la fois du gouvernement du
pays et de son avenir
donc il a pu manifester l'indifférence
au total ce prologue dans les provinces
comme on disait autrefois pour ses nus
pour ces élections et ainsi qu'entre
campagne chaude aux campagnes et
aujourd'hui il considère qu'il n'a rien
à voir avec les résultats alors que son
parti s'est effondré ou du moins on se
prendrait il existe et il n'a pas
beaucoup maigri et le parti mais il a
disparu
il n'a même pas atteint les 10% des
suffrages exprimés au premier tour est
on a un système où l'élection
présidentielle aujourd'hui est la seule
à dépasser les 50% de femmes expriment
au premier tour pour dernière élection
présidentielle en 2017 c'était 22 22 %
d'abstention mais toutes les autres
élections depuis une décennie
je dis bien nous décennies si on prend
tous les scrutins pas que l'élection il
y a eu ce scrutin sur lesquels sept ont
enregistré des scores de plus de 50%
d'abstention
donc ce ne sont pas que les élections
régionales cantonales partielles
différentes aux citoyens se sont ils
compris les municipales enfin des
élections dont on dit que les électeurs
sont proches de leurs représentants il y
a aujourd'hui une déstabilisation
complète la démocratie représentative
c'est tout c'est tout mais c'est pas mal
quand maman on va parler sans doute dans
la démocratie associative participative
qui devrait être dans la constitution
d'une république démocratique
et bien non on va de plus en plus vers
un système oligarchique où le président
décide y compris du choix de son de son
contradicteur aux élections marie le pen
à vocation alors qu'elle s'est effondrée
elle aussi dans ces élections
elle a vocation à être l'interlocutrice
consacré par le président sortant pour
le print présidentielle lorsque tous
aller les français ne veulent pas le
veulent plus et le goût de les urnes
parce que effectivement il n'ya pas de
répondre de manquera donc à leurs
attentes
alors on va entendre maxime thiébaut un
paul alliès donc dénonce un système
oligarchique pour lui mais il faut que
ça change notamment par le biais d'une
vième république est-ce que vous
rejoignez ce constat la vraie question
c'est de savoir où se situe la
légitimité démocratique de l'exercice
réel du pouvoir
ce qu'on constate depuis vingt ans et
que le pouvoir n'est plus exercée en
france le pouvoir a été internationalisé
vous avez la construction européenne
vous avez l'influencent de l'om c'est
vous avez l'influencent de différents
organismes internationaux et qui font
que ces organismes ont le pouvoir que
ces organismes influence le droit
français et la politique française parce
que nous sommes soumis par des contrats
internationaux à ce que note loiret ce
fait ces derniers et donc la vraie
question en fait c'est pas de passer une
sixième république ou revenir à une
sorte de quatrième qui porterait pas son
nom la vraie question à mon sens c'est
îlienne correspondance entre l'exercice
du pouvoir et la légitimité démocratique
aujourd'hui on a beau regarder l'elysée
on avons gardé l'assemblée nationale on
a beau regarder le sénat en réalité 80%
des lois qui sont imposés sur le
territoire national ne sont que des
retranscriptions de directives
européennes
nous avons les mains liées il est là le
vrai problème et les français l'ont
compris
c'est à dire que lorsqu'ils disent lors
de l'élection présidentielle façon peu
importe pour qui on votera ça ne
changera rien c'est il exprime en fait
la réalité de cette dépossession du roi
et moi je pense que ça dépasse en fait
la question de savoir si on 25e une
sixième rang
l'icc dans le fond je pense qu'on a un
problème qui est celui d'avoir un peu
plus de proportionnalité au niveau de la
représentation législatives je pense que
les grandes régions qu'on a conçu en
2015 ne correspond pas et ne réalité10
psychologique des français c'est-à-dire
qu'il ne s'identifie pas à travers ces
régions je pense que les départements et
le conseiller général a été complètement
détruit par la réforme de 2015 et ses
systèmes de binômes ces gens hybride que
les français ne comprennent pas est à
mon sens il faut revenir à des choses
essentielles identifier le maire le
conseiller général avec des vrais
pouvoirs aussi dans des représentations
régionales et une proportionnelle à
l'assemblée nationale pour que on est un
peu de respiration et qu'on n'ait pas
une bipolarisation de la vie politique
récupérez pouvoir paul alliès peut-être
votre réaction sur ce qui vient d'être
dit tant qu'il y aura des directives
européennes
au fond changer la constitution changer
les règles du jeu ça ne sert à rien est
ce que vous attendez là dessus je
discours politique les deux déjà ancien
sur la sonorité défaillante
les jeunes quand ils se manifester mon
interlocuteur semble bien connaître
puisqu'il affirme bouquin dessus ils ont
pour la première fois de plus au moins
mes 68 ou la question n'est jamais été
posée lier la question de la démocratie
représentative à cette démocratie
participative
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne par
exemple qu'ils ont portés comme
revendication donc moi je suis pour qu
une république pluraliste pas qu'une ré
plus grand réseau native
présidentialiste quand nous l'avons mais
comment peut-on passer à une reconquête
de la souveraineté populaire sans mettre
à bas un système qui a détruit tous les
jours et qu'une simple présidentialiste
faudrait qu'on m'explique
donc moi je ne suis pas un fétichiste de
la 6ème république je trouve que la
cohabitation comme celle qu'on a connue
à l'époque de loft 1 avec chirac était
d'ailleurs un bon ils volent respiration
démocratique si on revenait à la lettre
de la constitution de 1958 on aurait
peut être un régime beaucoup plus
équilibrée où le gouvernement
responsable devant réellement
responsable devant le parlement
alors effectivement il faut que le
parlement soit élu de façon beaucoup
plus juste équilibre est proportionnelle
à l'allemande
par exemple profiter personnalités dont
il ya un tas de petites réformes à faire
d'autres petites réformes petites et
grandes
mais en nous les annonces de tout le
temps et jamais on devait faire
reprendre les prenais ma cran c'est vrai
les maquereaux il a également sur grande
grande modernisation c'est son temps
préféré une modernisation de
l'institution
il n'a depuis la terre benalla il a fait
rien c'est toutefois catastrophique
alors en tout cas il a rien de fait mais
rien de rien il sera le président qui
aura le moins de push et nous dit pas la
constitution au système politique
bayrou ya trois mois demandez le
proportionnel toute simple en fait c'est
simple tu base elle est pratiquée
partout en europe dans l'union
européenne soit à l'angleterre
et bien non on ne répondent même pas 2
et contre le mépris total d'aurelien un
système qui le répète est un système où
en présidant irresponsable irresponsable
de décide de tout et notamment de la
congélation de l'es17 démocratique alors
maximum pour répondre à mon
interlocuteur
moi je suis pour que le match de rennes
cedex un problème qu'il attend depuis
des siècles passion était populaire et
nationale 1 c'est pas un problème qu'on
découvre aujourd'hui ça passe par là
l'intégration d'un système représentatif
démocratique à de nouvelles formes de
mokrani participative
ça c'est la 6ème république alors moi si
on me propose si on ne propose pas moins
d'infections proposer aux français je
crois et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est
bien souvent le sondage 67% des français
jusqu'à 67 points à spirales jm
république
ça fait trois sondages en trois sondages
alors quand on regarde son de là dessus
ils répondent
mais encore une fois ce n'est pas le
jour et la nuit
la 6ème république ou la 4e alors ça le
coût de la cam l'a fait plusieurs fois
la question respiration démocratique
système parlementaire et du système de
la république française traditionnelle
se pose à liaison avec des formes autres
de reconquête de la souveraineté
populaire
voilà maxime gilles la question du
6ème république c'est vrai quand on pose
la question aux français disent oui
parce qu'il voit bien que le système ne
fonctionne plus celui de la cinquième
après on peut leur poser des questions
sur la forme ils auront tous une réponse
différente de cette 6ème république
moi je suis convaincu que on à arriver à
maturité en arriver à une maturité du
peuple français qui est celle d'une
monarchie républicaine c'est à dire
qu'ils sont attachés à la présence d'un
homme d'état fort
par contre là je fais le même constat
que vous c'est que depuis 20-30 ans on a
des prises en a accueilli qui sont
catastrophiques elle problème c'est que
le siège est trop beau pour des gens qui
n'ont pas la compétence
et ça c'est un réel problème et je pense
qu'il faut arriver à trouver à maintenir
ce chef d'état fort comme arbitre et
d'avoir eu une respiration démocratique
à côté par une une refonte de
l'assemblée nationale sur son mode de
scrutin est une vraie démocratie locale
et l'outillage du référendum même
d'initiative populaire moi je n'ai
jamais défendu dans livre je pense que
cette c'est un très très bel outil le
référendum d'initiative populaire parce
qu'il permet de temps en temps au peuple
de pouvoir dire là il ya des limites qui
sont franchies et je crois aussi je pose
la question je pense qu'elle doit être
réfléchi à l'idée d'avoir une dose de
personnes tirées au sort dans l'ensemble
des votes des assemblées représentatives
françaises pour avoir cette petite
respiration qui viendraient comme ça du
sort mais qui peut nous faire naître des
gens qui auraient une compétence qui
n'auraient pas été identifié et qui
sortirait d'un système purement
représentatif
on oublie très souvent que le tirage au
sort a été abandonné par les penseurs de
la renaissance qui finalement ont
préféré dépendent défendre le système
représentatif
quand je pense qu'il ya un vrai débat
est là où je suis d'accord fin sur sur
l'ensemble avec eux avec monsieur alliès
c'est que il faut poser ce débat
clairement l'élection présidentielle de
2022 devrait être cet enjeu là et
malheureusement j'ai l'impression qu'on
va encore se perdre dans le faux duel le
maquereau le pen qui va nous occuper sur
les questions d'immigration et de
sécurité en éclipsant l'essentiel qui
est en réalité l'organisation
institutionnelle de notre pays
mais s'il reste quelques jours peut-être
une dernière question alors avant de
penser à une refonte totale du système
et du mode de scrutin certains comme à
la république en marche un pouce pour le
veut
électronique ou à distance pour
davantage mobiliser les français c'est
une bonne idée ou pas je vous vois rire
tous les deux paul ier salazie ya pas
que ça fait la vente hier depuis 48
heures des propositions qui sortent ni
comme un lapin d'un chapeau de magicien
sur la modernisation celartem jeu
préféré de ben rhouma qu'on quitte et à
la modernisation du système électoral
qui est assez rigolo mais c'est vraiment
très drôle alors en général les mêmes
quelquefois en rase campagne demande le
vote obligatoire
malgré ces contretemps obligatoire que
dans votre sanction qui veut sanctionner
de la voulait on ne remonte pas
obligatoire on va on va finir 66 %
d'abstentionnistes quelques cette
histoire dont on personnes l'europe a
par contre alors le vote électronique il
ya le calendrier électoral on va réunir
les élections régionales département et
municipales rendez vous compte des
transformations les législatives
havel est présentie à la catastrophe
parce que c'est déjà le parlement
assommé par le président qui est élu le
15 août trois semaines avant le tie
break
nakhonay des blagues servir des gens qui
n'ont pas réfléchi et qui ne vole pas
transformer aussi c'est le mot de la fin
d'accord le mot de la fin prévient
maxime c'est la politique du gadget qui
ne s'intéressent pas l'essentiel
vous savez tombe à ce jeune c'est
spontané c'est secouer les chaînes d'une
civilisation périmés macro et nous fait
du gadget c'est la start up nation qui a
complètement oublié qu'il faut réformer
nos institutions et notre constitution
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce matin en direct sur rt
france merci à vous paul alliès
professeur émérite à l'université de
montpellier président de la convention
pour la 6ème république merci à vous
maxime thiébaut docteur en droit public
auteur du livre gilet jaune vers une
démocratie réelle